-Joy, thank you so much
for coming on the show.
It's great to have you on.
-It is great to be on.
Jimmy, it's so fun being
on the show.
I'm so excited.
I apologize for being
in my closet...
-[ Laughs ]
-...but we're having
some work done
in the house this week
-I love it!
-and I wanted to make sure
it was quiet, so it's the
quietest place in the house.
So I'm in my closet.
-Oh, this is fantastic.
Any fan of shoes,
people are like,
this is like they're
geeking out right now.
They're so jealous
of your collection.
I have so many things
I wanna talk to you about.
Congrats on "The ReidOut,"
by the way.
It launched in July
and it's doing fantastic,
crushing in the ratings.
I was looking at some
information about you
and you're the first
woman of color
to anchor a primetime news
show on MSNBC
and you're also the only
Black woman currently anchoring
a primetime news show
on any of the major networks.
-Yeah.
-That is --
What an accomplishment.
What does that mean to you?
-Yeah, it's daunting, right?
I mean, and when it
kinda sunk in
that I was gonna be doing this,
it felt really big.
You know, I grew up, you know,
being a news junkie
from sixth grade on.
And, you know, everyone that was
sort of telling me the world
and telling me about the news,
the Ted Koppels of the world,
the Dan Rathers,
all the people that I admired,
it was all white guys, right?
-Yeah.
-There were very few
people like me
that I could really see on TV,
so when I finally saw
Gwen Ifill, it was like...
♪ Ahhh ♪
...your know?
I just revered her
'cause it was so exciting.
Carole Simpson and Gwen Ifill
were the only Black women
that I can remember growing up.
-Yeah.
-Connie Chung, the only
other woman of color.
So the very few women of color
that I've seen in this space,
I've always gravitated
toward them.
I finally did get a chance
to meet Gwen Ifill
before she passed.
I was so excited.
I ran across the street
in Selma, Alabama,
and threw myself on top of her
to give her a hug.
-Wow!
-She was very nice about it
and let me take a selfie
with her, which I treasure, so,
yeah, it's big because,
for some little kid, you know,
some little Black girl,
I'm like that to them, in a way.
Like they're maybe seeing me
and feeling like,
"Okay, I can do this.
This is something
that I could do."
-Yeah. That's exactly right!
-Yeah.
"I can do that.
I can be that," yeah.
We should talk about some
of the news that's happening.
Obviously,
today is the 19th anniversary
of the September 11th attacks.
-Yeah.
-Were you working in news then?
What do you remember
about that day?
-I was. I mean, by then,
we had three young kids,
but we were living in Florida
and I was now working
for the NBC affiliate
WTVJ in Miami
and I remember it was
my day off, actually.
9/11, I was having an off day
and my brother
had come up from Denver
and was staying with us
and I remember him yelling,
"Oh, S-word!
A plane just hit
the World Trade Center."
And, at first, I thought maybe
it was just a wrong-way plane
'cause we had actually
had a story like that
not long before that, in Miami,
where a guy just went off-track
and hit a building.
So I'm thinking this is
just a wrong-way plane.
By the time I walked
down the stairs,
the second plane hit
and that's when we all realized
this is not a wrong-way plane.
This is serious.
Phone went off.
I had to go in to work.
It was shocking.
I think I was so stunned
for the first,
probably, you know,
six or seven hours,
that it didn't hit me,
but, when it did, I will admit,
I'm not ashamed to admit
I just cried
and I don't cry at work.
I try not to ever cry at work,
you know,
no matter how tough the story.
But I cried that day
and then, the day that --
I don't know if you remember
the Boys Choir of Harlem
did a thing where they went
into Yankee Stadium
and they sang
"We Shall Overcome,"
to try to cheer New York up
-Ohh!
-and I just -- I lost it.
-Gosh!
-Like, you know, yeah.
-And then, to see the city
come back and also --
is pretty inspiring as well.
-Yeah.
-And to see the first responders
and everyone helping,
doing whatever they can
to help each other
and I was like, "Oof!"
-New York is still
the greatest city in the world.
-Oh!
-It just is.
It's the most resilient.
People are like,
"New Yorkers aren't friendly."
No, New Yorkers will give you
the shirt off their back.
They will do anything for you.
New York comes together
like no other city
and rebounds like no other city,
even with what's happening now.
-I agree.
-I was just in New York
recently.
New York is fightin'
its way back.
Nothing can stop New York.
-What else is happening
in the news?
I guess everyone's still talking
about Bob Woodward's book
and those tapes!
-Ah!
-I just don't quite
understand it.
What are your takes?
So, basically,
the president admitted
that he downplayed the threats
-Yeah.
-of coronavirus.
It just had a lot of stuff,
but what was he thinking?
Why would he do that?
-And here's the thing, Jimmy.
It's not even as if Bob Woodward
called the White House
switchboard and said,
"Let me talk to Trump.
Let me talk to him just
for five minutes."
No, Trump called him.
On one of the critical phone
calls where he admitted
that he was just downplaying it,
even though he knew
that this was a deadly virus,
that -- oh! -- is airborne.
Not only that, the day
that he called Bob Woodward
and gave him that
on-the-record interview
where he's like,
"I'm playing it down.
I like to play it down,"
he held a rally that day.
I mean, he literally,
in the contemporaneous period.
And then, kept holding rallies.
And then stopped for a while
and then went right back
and did it, in Tulsa,
the day after Juneteenth.
This man has known
the whole time.
You know, I did a commentary
on the show the other day,
where I said, "Look,
at the end of the day,
Donald Trump
has lost his credibility
with people like me,"
people who cover him
day in and day out
and who have --
you know, I've written
a book about him.
I've interviewed all
of his biographers, nearly,
people who've worked with him.
people who worked
on "The Apprentice."
Very difficult for me to take
him at face value when he talks.
But his supporters do.
They believe everything he says.
It's them
he's primarily lying to.
It's them who he's convinced
not to wear masks.
It's them who will take
his advice and try bleach
and thinking that
that will help them.
It's them!
-Oh, my God.
-And then, they put
the rest of us in danger
because they won't
protect themselves.
-I'm sure you saw
the rally last night,
with everyone with --
It was just --
-Unbelievable.
-I-I --
-And they played "Fortunate Son"
as like the intro song.
-It's just so -- it's bizarre.
I wanna talk
about your big project
with Peacock and MSNBC
tomorrow night at 10:00,
-Yeah.
-but it's a documentary
called "The Sit-In."
I'm hosting "The Tonight Show,"
so I know the story,
but a lot of people
might not know this story.
Do you wanna explain
what "The Sit-In" is about?
-Yeah. Jimmy,
I didn't know it, either.
Like I did not know that --
And, you know,
we talked early on
about the idea of, you know,
me hosting, you know,
a primetime news show.
As you know,
late night is very similar,
in terms of the demographics
of the people
who've dominated late night,
you know, since the 1950s.
You know, Johnny Carson,
of course,
being the guy who made
late night into late night,
-Yeah.
-created this
incredible platform
that you, you know,
are blessed to continue
and that we're thankful
that you're continuing, so.
But you also know
that the platform
has generally been
about a breath, right?
It's like Walter Cronkite
at 6:00 and then, a deep breath
-Yeah!
-for late night,
when you can just chill.
-Yeah.
-Right?
And that's what it was.
But Johnny had an ethos.
Johnny, he was a little,
you know,
he was a little bit of a social
gangster, a little bit.
He was like, "I'm a little
gangster with this.
I'm gonna do something big."
He took this platform and he
gave it to the first Black man
to ever host in late night,
and that Black man is
Harry Belafonte.
February 1968, middle part
of the civil rights movement.
You know, violence and riots
had been going on
over police killings
and abuse of Black people.
It was a really difficult
time in America.
You know, Johnny Carson
hands this week over
to Harry Belafonte and he says,
"Do whatever you want with it."
And Harry says, "You know
what I'm gonna do with it?
I'm gonna go big.
Yes, I'm gonna have on
Aretha Franklin,
Buffy Sainte-Marie,
like great entertainers.
But I'm also gonna have on
my political friends,"
political people,
and he had on the two biggest,
in terms of social gospel --
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
-I've seen it.
-and Robert F. Kennedy.
And he does the last --
the interviews,
especially with Dr. King,
I think this was
his last recorded interview.
-It's a great documentary.
It's called "The Sit-In."
It's on Peacock currently
and tomorrow night on MSNBC.
-Yes.
-I wanna show a clip.
Here is a clip
from "The Sit-In."
Check it out.
-Well, I'm delighted
to be here, Harry,
and I'll tell you one
of the reasons
I'm so happy to be here.
I flew out of Washington
this afternoon
and, as soon as we started out,
they notified us
that the plane
had mechanical difficulties
and I don't want to give you
the impression that,
as a Baptist preacher, I don't
have faith in God in the air.
It's simply that I've had
more experience with Him
on the ground.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I was kind of amused that he
knew how to get laughter,
which is something that you
don't see in his speeches
because he's so serious.
My thing was like, "Oh!
He can tell a good joke."
-Fantastic!
Joy Reid, everybody.
I also wanna mention
"The Man Who Sold America,"
your best-selling book
is now in paperback,
with brand-new chapters.
Go check that out.
Also, please watch
"The Sit-In" on Peacock now.
We'll be right back
with a performance
from the Flaming Lips.
Thank you again, Joy,
for being here.
-Thank you, Jimmy,
for having me. Bye-bye.